okay and we're back y'all
and we're back let's do it
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
you know what it is
your favorite podcast
[Music]
welcome back to ripping with Griffin and
we doing it live once again today
American Idol cause I love it
NBA playoffs again I saw this show silo
I want to talk about that
but your news and notes comments uh
General discussions about stuff you know
how we do back here once again
I'll rip it with Griffin so
you know how we do it
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome back to
riffing with Griffin here we are you
know oh this worked this week look at
that my little my little sign worked
right there I don't know why it doesn't
you know it just it actually doesn't
make any sense when it doesn't work you
know what I mean it's like what are you
talking about I don't know why that
didn't show up right there oh well so
anyways
um welcome back to where from with
Griffin
you know how we do here on Riverwood
Griffin we do it live if you've been
here before thank you for being here as
always you know what I do if this is
your first time you just happen to be
catching it or you heard about it
um you know welcome welcome to Riverwood
Griffin we uh I um sometimes I'm funny
sometimes I'm introspective sometimes
it's silly but it's always 100
authentically me okay so there's that
why isn't this shown now I don't
understand why nothing's working you
know it doesn't make any sense I don't
get it anyways now that showed up it
don't make any sense so make sure you
subscribe when you subscribe you know
you're going to get the notifications
and all that good stuff so hit the
Subscribe button there I don't know why
that didn't oh there it is you know
subscribe button is showing up uh I'm on
Twitch most days so check me out on
Twitch
and if you want to support the show you
can like be a YouTube member you could
be a twitch member sub you know just to
support me if that's what you want to do
or you'll be a patreon member I have a
very small patreon community because I
need to like do some regular videos on
there right I always say I'm going to
but it just you know stuff happens man
it just turns out you know I don't know
let's see if this show oh there it is
finally that showed up
yeah
oh man I don't know so welcome back to
referring with Griffin nothing to report
this week
nothing major to report in uh well
actually yeah let's see
so I know I've talked about this before
about
uh Rachel
she's like she likes to look at Tick
Tock stuff so she
so she she always got these things about
washing strawberries and how you
supposed to wash those so first it was
like you know you don't watch them you
know you you run some water over them
you wash them but then like you know
when you get these reports on Tick Tock
where it'll be like oh if you don't
watch the strawberries
or there'll be some invest not
investigation but there'll be some sort
of sciency person who will be like hey
take a look at these strawberries
underneath the microscope when you don't
wash them and then you know she sees
that and she's like oh my God so she's
like make sure you wash the fruit she's
always like washing the fruit so
remember it was like then she was
washing them in hot water and then which
was ridiculous because like you're
cooking the fruit so the other day now
she has a thing where not only do you
wash them in hot water but you put salt
in the hot water
but you're supposed to
get the hot water in the salt wash them
real you put them in you dump them and
then take them out Rachel kept the
strawberries on the counter in a bowl in
hot water and salt for like an hour
I go in there in this strawberry soup
she didn't cook the strawberries so they
it was just a waste of the strawberry so
what so what I had to do is I had to put
the strawberries
they were all they were like you
couldn't even pick them up they were
like gooey it was terrible so I had to
take the stems off and I put them in a
plastic bag because I just use them for
smoothies you know
when the fruits start to get bad I'll
put the fruit in a bag put it in the
freezer and then I'll put you know and
then you can use that for smoothies but
Rachel always
it's like whatever's that's why Tick
Tock needs to be stopped
Tick Tock needs to be stopped because
she'll go on a rabbit hole and then
she'll send me all these things about
strawberries and what you know and I'm
like okay well now we now now we're in a
rut of you know we're in like you know
strawberry decline right now all right
so I don't know
thanks for being here on the chat you
know and if people
want to comment
so let's go over some comments
uh uh Benji Sevilla I don't know nine
three three five six people should just
put your real names you know what I mean
start your comment with hey this is such
so-and-so so I know your real name
because this these usernames are stupid
he goes I've watched the movie review
video about five times no lie it's like
my comfort food to me well that's nice
it's probably really my voice you know
what I mean I don't know
um Christopher
Topher said things are different now
you're a hat guy hilarious
yeah y'all wait let me put my hat on
from last week
put last week's hat on y'all uh oh there
it is uh he's supposed to turn it just a
little bit right yeah hat guy is back
every time I get on here now I start
coughing and stuff it only no sense put
my headphones down I don't need them
hi guys back uh let's see what else we
got here
um I don't know what this one is about
oh there's some of these comments I've
just seen for the first time so let's
like you know we gotta you know hide
user from Channel that's that's how I do
that
uh
uh anyways and that one idiot is coming
back with his please make it a 20 minute
podcast so you know that's just a troll
troll idiot now uh
uh okay Jolie Adventures the cop the
cowboy hat makes you look like my
Mexican uncle
's I love it you invited to the
the carne asada stupid
um
let's see Mike Harrison said let Shadow
ban YouTube and Facebook and make them
change their ways
Griffin who's this one Anonymous oh I
hate when people's name is anonymous
something Anonymous hippopotamus 345
stupid name Griff you look like a
villain from an old-timey silent Western
getting ready to tie a woman to to a
train track
remember when they used to do that in
that it would be a big thing the villain
would always tie the woman to the train
track it's like why that's what torture
that is huh
um okay so let's see Philly 553 I feel I
feel that the 24 hour news and sports
coverage has become more about creating
content than actually reporting facts
and events a lot of hours needed to be
filled so so more opinions versus just
facts
I like that that was from Philly I feel
the same way
uh let's see these hunt 4883 I don't
know if anybody said that name right
love you fool
uh somebody got caught off guard because
I mentioned them
let's see uh here's another let's get
back to the Matt Rife comments when is
Matt coming on again
I don't care about Matt just like he's
getting you engagements also let me be a
guest on the pod
that's for that's man people
let's see John
machinga 9858 the combo cowboy hat is
fire so anyways guys thanks for you know
your comments
yes I only do get a com I do game on
somebody's in if you're listening live
right now if you're in the YouTube live
right now thanks for being here I'm
gonna try to look at some of what you
guys are saying right there so thank you
and uh yes I I only I I play on Xbox and
Playstation for the people that are
asking about my gaming
um you know one of those uh uh the
episode I did about Tucker Carlson a few
few weeks ago
um I actually want to put up a poll
right here for the people that are
watching live right now and I would like
to
um ask you that are listening if you
want to comment you know on the YouTube
or even wherever you we comment stuff
here's my question and I'm not saying I
don't want people to to
say what you personally would do but you
can if you want to okay
because I think a lot of people when
you're typing on a keyboard behind a
monitor it's easy to pretend like
you would do the right thing quote
unquote whatever that means
but my question is you know can you be
bought
you know do you have think of your best
friend or think of somebody that you're
really close to in your life no matter
what their political affiliation is
if one of if the opposite side Network
you know so let's so let's say you're uh
a Fox News person you you swear by Fox
News or you swear by uh what is the
other one the you know the wired
something all the you know all the
conservative news
if you swear by that
would how much what how much can you be
bought so then CNN comes to you and says
hey I want you to actually be a CNN
correspondent and here's 10 million
dollars
are you now
are you now would you do it would your
friends do it would you think your
friend would do it you know what I mean
do you think your favorite host would do
it
you know I just look at like I think
Tucker Carlson made something like 20
million dollars probably more than that
and so uh listen I'm just I'm gonna
speak for me okay
for 20 million dollars the whole Obama
family would get it
okay you know what I'm saying I don't
know I'm just being 100. I'm just I'm
just keeping it real man it's like Fox
comes to me like we want you to be a we
want you to be one of those opinion show
correspondents but here's the thing you
have to talk about Biden and you have to
trash the Obamas 20 million dollars I
mean it would be hard to like you know
you you change your family's life you
know
where do you
you gotta be like you can say what you
would do you know you could say well you
think your friend like oh yeah my best
friend would for sure do that like think
of your most conservative friend your
most liberal friend like would your most
liberal woke friend you go to them and
go here's a 20 million dollars and I
need you to go you're gonna be on FOX
NOW do you think they would change sides
what's the number you know what I mean
because I think most of y'all that are
even commenting right now would do it
for a hundred thousand dollars
you know what I'm saying
I don't know how much you make a year
but
let's say let's say they came to you and
said all right we need you to be on here
once a week and we're going to give you
a 175
000 but here's the talking points you
have to like what's your number what's
your number what's your personal if you
don't want to say for you you know you
could be like oh hypothetically my
friend but you could be talking about
you but anyways it's just I just I think
about it more and more each week as I
and you know Tucker costumes going to
tick tock not Tick Tock got Twitter now
he's gonna do a show on Twitter which I
think is a genius idea and I'm actually
interested to watch because I want to
see if
because he was his his last post he put
up he put up just great posts about and
he was talking about both sides of the
media and like big corporations and I
was like oh man I love this are we gonna
get the like the realness of like who he
is now and I think that's gonna be a
fascinating watch so
anyways
well you know I mean like can you be
bought that's really the question okay
so uh we're back guys let's talk about
the NBA okay
um I'm loving the NBA right now
MBA is like you as if you've been
watching the podcast you know I've just
been kind of off on the NBA recently you
know
um I'm not gonna put anything on the
screen just talk about it myself right
now so if you listen it's perfect for
you you guys I have to remember that
people listen on Apple and Google and
all that stuff so all right so we're now
we're into it last week
in the East let's talk about the East
okay so first of all we got to put
respect on the Miami Heat's name like we
are we have to start to realize that the
Miami Heat actually have been a pretty
great Organization for the last four or
five years the fact that they got to the
championship in the bubble but we think
about the bubble and we go I was the
bubble right but they did make it and
then ever since they they have they've
been far in the playoffs now for the
last four years since then since they
haven't made it back to the championship
but they made it to the Conference
Finals they made it to you know they got
a lot of wins a lot of playoff wins they
actually have more playoff wins than a
lot of teams that are left in the last
four years
so that's pretty fascinating so you know
it's just when you look at that team you
have one star Jimmy Butler who only
seems to like show that stardom in the
playoffs and here we are and it's kind
of like an a nothing
um series because it's like the New York
Knicks and they haven't been relevant in
35 years so it's like nobody cares about
the Knicks for me unless you're in New
York but like the rest of us we don't
care so that series is kind of like who
are the stars of that series you know
it's like it's like a really blue collar
series you got Jalen Brunson who is like
this little stocky he doesn't look
flashy he don't look like a typical
atypical prototype NBA star but the
kid's a baller you know what I mean like
it's because of him that Dallas went to
the Conference Finals the year before
and now we're realizing that it wasn't
Luca it was Jalen Brunson okay he he was
the the engine that made that team be
good and so now we're seeing that
because look what happened to Dallas
with him gone and then here you know you
know what I mean so and then you got uh
what's his name um what's that big guy's
name uh that plays for the Knicks man uh
I forget his name you know he just he
said something real stupid you know he
was like maybe they want it more than us
it's like what he used to be a Laker he
could help me out guys he used to be a
Laker anyways that guy like the Knicks
are cooked they're done they're down 3-1
mime is going to take care of them so
then so in Miami once again is going to
go to the Conference Finals now
I have said all along that the Celtics
yeah Julius Randle thank you Julius
Randle He just he don't got it man and I
was watching First Take and Stephen A
Smith was talking about how Julius
Randle stats over the past five or so
years it's terrible he's one of the
worst in terms of his stats and how he
contributes to this team so anyways get
rid of him anyway anyway all right so
let's go to another series Celtic Sixers
now I called it
earlier like a week or two ago as I've
been talking about the NBA I think the
Sixers
are going to go to the championship and
so the past week now it's been up and
down and I thought the Celtics like okay
Celtics maybe the Celtics have got it
together and Joe Missoula is making his
uh adjustments but no I don't think so I
still think the Sixers are going to go
to the championship and I think they
have a good chance to win it but I feel
like that
the inexperience of Joe Missoula in
these situations is and I said this
weeks and weeks ago before all these Big
Time Sports shows were talking about
this I was talking about this
he don't got it man he don't got it yet
he will but not yet and the players
they're too they don't have like like
Jason Tatum is a great MVP type player
but he don't got that leadership
personality it don't seem like he got
that
thing that engine and makes galvanized
as a team and makes them you know
push forward and get their best when the
coach isn't doing what he's supposed to
do so I think they're going to get sent
home I don't think they're going to make
the championship but I wouldn't be
surprised if they do but if they make it
to the championship they're going to get
waxed by whoever wins the West
but I think the Sixers are in a position
for for Doc Rivers with his experience
for Doc Rivers to like get that monkey
off his back about being a choke coach
uh you know Joel embiid staying healthy
and James Harden getting that monkey off
his back of being like a choke artist in
the playoffs too I think this is a
perfect opportunity for the Sixers to
really show who they are well that's
going to Western Conference now all
right so I I'm really surprised that
Phoenix won the two games at day one but
at the same time I'm not surprised
because you're talking about two of the
greatest scorers and players
that that that this League's ever seen
just scored 71 points in a game before
so this dude is a score and he had two
of the greatest game stretches that a PL
any player has ever had in NBA history
so yeah he had to do that for the Suns
to win and he did you know Denver
stopped playing defense for some reason
and Devin Booker even though Kevin
Durant was struggling he was still
making an impact on the game and so and
then and then the game four that Kevin
Durant finally was like okay I'm Kevin
Durant again and it you know it's hard
to beat a team like that with those two
guys clicking but they can't click
forever and that's exactly what happened
game five Denver came out Devin Booker
missed a bunch of shots you know he was
shooting 80 percent before that's
impossible that's 2K stuff and so now
now they're back down to normal you see
a team that like doesn't have enough so
could they still win the series for sure
you know because you know he could get
hot Kevin Durant can get hot at any time
I don't think it's gonna happen I think
Denver is going to close it out in the
next game in Phoenix uh and you know but
I will say this I have a change of heart
about Phoenix
I actually think that Kevin Durant
reminds me of Shaquille O'Neal
at the later stage of his career when he
went to Miami
he wasn't the dominant player that he
was but still really great but Dwyane
Wade was the best player on the team so
that's what I think of uh
Devin book Devin Bookers bet Devin
Booker right now is better than Kevin
Durant he's just better he's more he's
younger he's faster he's got you know
what I mean his body stays healthier and
even he gets hurt but still I think that
that's the thing he's the best player on
the team and Kevin Durant his presence
and everything that he brings
he has times where he don't need to be
great
super great every game but he gives
enough and then he can be great you know
what I mean so I know there's some of
you that think sons and seven
I don't know man I think Denver is just
too good they've been the best team all
year so it shouldn't be surprising
you know they can have bad games and
they still almost won those games that
they you know what I mean even with
Devin Booker scoring 80 percent click
right just scoring that he was hitting
80 of his shots the other team Jamal
Murray was just tired look like Jamal
Murray missed like five wide open shots
in game three where they they could have
put him away and it was like you Denver
lost that game
even with those guys playing as great as
they were playing it was still a close
game down the stretch so I just think
Denver is a better team
now let's go to the Lakers and Golden
State
Lakers are up 3-1
tell me you're not shocked that the
Lakers are up 3-1 you gotta be man you
got to be shocked that the Lakers are up
to one I'm a little shocked and now as
I'm watching them I'm seeing what this
team has turned into and I like it I
like it speaking of likes let's get
these likes up everybody 81 people
watching right now you know I need 81
likes what are you guys doing
that helps spread the algorithms help
spread the show and if you're listening
right now go give me a review on Apple
you know hit the review thing because
that also helps more people to listen to
the podcast but anyways
um
well almost one he goes this is this
idiot in the chat says almost one equal
is lost in a seven game series
almost winning carries over to the next
game that's important
how you play and the adjustments that
you make and when you almost win because
you didn't do a certain thing you carry
that over into the next game and do
those things and you win it's why Denver
won by 20 and held the Suns
to uh less than the points that they've
been scoring so almost winning in a
seven game series is important
anyways I digress you know
so
go over to Lakers now Lakers I we I
surprising what the Lakers are doing but
I like the team but they've turned into
like LeBron James right now
is like he's like you could tell he's
like damn I'm old
I gotta I gotta watch what I do and he's
using himself as a decoy and a presence
on the court that it's great I mean I
just think it's great how his team is
rallying behind his leadership
you know and it's like he's putting it
out there he had that foot injury he's
probably still a little injured and you
know he just shows up when he needs to
shows up and he's doing all the other
things you know he'll get 20 11 rebounds
eight assists five blocks you know he's
doing all the things and allowing all
the other guys on the team to shine and
Anthony Davis is finally showing up
Anthony Davis is finally showing up you
know
um
but he always shows up on defense and
now he's starting to like realize oh man
I I got to get 20 plus per game or we're
not gonna win because all the talk about
him is like that's the talk all the time
you know he every other game he doesn't
do well so you know he didn't show up he
had four shots in the second half but
his defensive presence and all that he
was doing and the adjustments that both
teams made was great and so we'll see
what happens right now you know and then
that Lonnie guy Lonnie Anderson or
whatever his name is Lonnie
Lonnie Walker he comes in and scores 15
points in the fourth quarter that is
because of LeBron James man about like
being on his team or being like stay
ready we're gonna need you and then like
you know you you know you're you're
looking at this dude imagine playing
with LeBron James right now and you're
like damn I'm playing with like the
greatest player of my era I'm playing
with somebody who's on the Mount
Rushmore who people consider better than
Michael Jordan some people right and you
now have a chance to help him push his
legacy forward that means something you
know what I mean that really means
something so I like how the Lakers are
playing now conversely on the other side
Golden State I don't know what's going
on with that man
I think this is it for the Golden State
uh Dynasty I think the team is imploding
Jordan Poole I don't know what's going
on with him he's not playing well you
know he's like him and Draymond Green
are just never gonna get along you know
they never gonna give us give each other
birthday gifts
Steph Curry like last series had to go
you know Draymond Green's trying to tell
something to uh him and he just kind of
brushes him off and then Steph Curry has
to go talk to him what the hell is your
problem right and then dap up Jamar
green it's like Whoa man they got issues
Klay Thompson I don't know what's going
on with that dude
he is not showing up and then he's
shooting shots and then the bench is
like oh man why would you do that it's
like damn
this dude's had 50 in games before this
dude's had you know 10 threes in a and a
half one time and and the bench is
looking at him like he's not supposed to
be shooting so that was kind of like
whoa what's going on with that so I
don't know if they got it Steph Curry's
trying his best but they're just not the
same kind of team they're not as young
as they were Steph Curry could give you
50 whenever he wants like he's like he's
really balling but it's not enough it's
not gonna be enough to me for me to beat
the Lakers they're not going to come
back from this that would be an epic
Collapse by the Lakers and I just don't
see that happening
I don't see that team they're bigger
they're stronger they're better
defensively
and they're smarter
I just think they're smarter and I I
don't see them losing three games in a
row the Lakers or however many games
yeah yeah because they're up 3-1 so
anyways that's the NBA talk everybody
NBA talk
um okay I want to talk about this show
that I've been watching uh it's called
Silo
um
it's on Apple TV I don't know if you
guys got Apple TV not a lot of people
have Apple TV so I totally get if you
don't have Apple TV you know
I mean it is what it is
um
anyways this show
I'm gonna read a description from IMDb
it's called a men and women live in a
giant Silo underground with several
regulations which they believe are in
place to protect them from the toxic and
ruined World on the surface where all
the zombies live oh I didn't know there
were zombies in this okay that's
interesting so
I like I like this show okay this is
about like
so this is like one of these like
post-apocalyptic the world is the world
is dead we've ruined the planet and
these are the people that have survived
and they're living in this sort of
underground Cavern like the Matrix or
something you know what I mean it's like
there's so many shows shows and movies
that have this sort of like theme of
people living in you know underground
you know because the world is ruined we
have to do this right
great acting going on in this show this
Rebecca Ferguson she's she's in um Dune
she plays the mom and doom she's a great
actress but it's only episode two so far
that I've watched and I I like this show
but like I've seen this kind of show so
many times
that you know what we're waiting for
we're waiting to find out why they are
really in there and we know that it's
not what they're portraying it to be
right so now it's like the question is
is it gonna pay off
is when we find out the truth about this
the what what's going on and and the
true bad guys you know because it's
always human beings who are messing
everything up you know you know there's
you know is there some secret Illuminati
or whatever like whatever we find out is
it gonna be worth the payoff because
that's what's happening in this show
so you know it's like
they're fine like somebody found some
secrets and you know and it's like oh
they had this great thing on the show
where it's like you can never say the
words I want to go outside that's like
against the law in The Silo and if you
say that
they'd send you outside
and there's like a camera
that shows the outside world
you know there's this camera that shows
this desolate world
and they tell people that are like I
want to go outside I don't want to be
here anymore
they asked them to clean and they would
they're supposed to clean off the camera
so the people inside they could see
what's going on and it's like a big
thing for when people clean
but then they eventually die right away
in front of the camera
so
it's like you know it's a very
it's a very slow paced show
and like I say you're waiting for this
like thing to happen
you know you're waiting for this thing
to happen and so I just hope it pays off
but in the process I'm enjoying so far
where it's going
and it's just because they got really
great actors on the show like these are
really great actors and they're just you
know and you and they've really it's
it's it's it's well done because they've
really set up this universe that you
believe and they really tell you
everything you need to know about you
know what's going on here like oh this
is how they live and this is their
system of government and then there's
like a higher hierarchy and we're sort
of starting in like the the low this
reminds me of that uh snow piercers have
you have you seen that movie with uh the
Captain America guy uh Chris Evans and
he's on a train and it's the same thing
the world is ruined and the only people
left live on a train and this train is
going on is is on a track that's just
going in like a big circle around the
world and these people are the only ones
left and they can't go outside because
the world is ruined it's super cold or
they'll die and they have these
different train cars with different like
you know these are the rich people these
are the you know so I feel like we're
gonna find out about Silo in the same
it's the same kind of thing so it's like
how are these people surviving in this
situation so
you know
we'll see so far I feel like it's pretty
good
um I don't know if anybody's watching it
you tell me what you think of it uh but
you know if you if you're into this sort
of like thing but the fact that they're
talking about there could be zombies is
like I don't know I didn't even I didn't
even that's the first time I've seen
that but that's the description that's
live on IMDb so maybe there's more more
that's gonna happen in this show than we
think which is pretty great
and it looks like it's getting a really
good
score really good rating so we'll see so
if you have
you know yeah I see somebody in the chat
talking about they made a snow piercer
show of course I mean that's one of
those it's one of those things where
it's like great concept but it can't
always be executed well not everybody
executes their shows well
or movies you go oh I love this concept
there was a Justin Timberlake movie like
that what was it called in time that I
think that was the name of it where
there's no more money and currency is
paid in time you know so they they
figured out to make everybody 25 years
old once you hit 25 you're stuck at 25
forever you know and then now you're
trading time you know and it's such a
great concept that I always thought that
would be a great television show to
watch you know but they fumbled they
fumbled the movie it wasn't it was like
good it was weird you know what I mean
so there's always stuff like that
um
anyways so there goes that Silo baby
silo
excuse me all right let's talk about
some news and notes that's going on in
the world well let me go to my let's go
to Instagram first uh here's like some
weird Instagram stories that I saw
oh I don't have a video no videos this
week so I'll just go back to the screen
cap this I thought this was really
hilarious
undercover cops posing as buyers
arrested by undercover cops posing as
dealers I
like if this is real
how stupid is that huh undercover cops
posing as buyers arrested by undercover
cops posing as dealers
like talk about not working together
well like what like I wonder how that I
would have liked to have seen that seems
like it's like one of those like scenes
in a movie where you know they're like
it's like the you know the bad guy
that's getting away
you know he's being chased by a cop and
then you know and then and then they see
other cops and then the guy runs over
and goes like that's the armed person
they're after me I I'm you know then
then the cops are like put your gun down
and the other guy's like I'm a cop I'm a
CIA agent or whatever and it's like one
of those moments so that's just like
that must have been that moment
like I wonder what the moment would have
been like when like so the dealer gets
arrested
[Laughter]
uh like
like how did that happen did both teams
like like were they both listening like
they had to everybody was wired you know
like what a complete waste of resources
dad tells me like these
how do y'all not know that this is going
on
like like so that means like
one they're in the they're in the their
their Precinct or whatever
and then you know one side of the room
they're over there working on their
thing all right we got these people and
then looking over there's another a
group of cops over there like oh yeah
this is gonna be good you know we'll
pose as buyers and then we're gonna get
them and the other guys are like they're
like what are you guys doing nothing
it's none of your business okay maybe
they have like some kind of competition
going like who can get the most arrests
or something you know and they're
obviously not talking to each other
about anything and then they're just
like oh well we got something cooking
today and the other team's like oh you
think you got something cooking we got
something cooking and then they just
like how do they what do they not know
each other are they you know what I mean
or whatever are they in there and
there's like two Vans parked on the
street like next to each other and then
and you know and then they both
everybody busts out everybody get down
no you'll get down then they're like
wait Bobby
it's like
John wait a minute I knew I recognized
you this just seems like this just seems
like the most stupid blunder
that you could possibly possibly do but
I just thought that was a funny story
here's another one would you get this
what do you guys think of this would you
get
superhero themed toilets
so there's so the people that are
listening it's like the back so you have
the toilet seat and the back of the
toilet seat is Iron Man and it's a
really detailed intricate looking
character and you're sitting on this I
mean this is like this is some straight
nerd stuff right here
you know
I mean all bad The Incredible Hulk one
is I don't know if it's real but like
this would be great
will you sitting on the toilet and I'm
and uh in The Incredible Hulk and sort
of hugging you as you're on the toilet
oh man the Black Panther one no I don't
like this one I don't I don't wanna I
don't wanna [__] on black panther I
already did with my review oh this like
if this one was real
ah
oh man dude like these are like
these are so silly they have a
Spider-Man one they have a Batman one
it's like I think it's all made by AI so
that's a whole other thing
oh you know what I should talk about and
I don't have it on my agenda but I am
going to talk about it anyway I want to
just talk a little bit about the writer
strike and just give you my little bit
of my thoughts about it
so you know the writers are on strike
because of residuals from streaming
services and probably just general
residuals and just the way the business
is going
I don't know if you know but like it
used to be you know you you know when it
was just networks like say NBC CBS or
something like that it was simple back
in the day there was no cable it was
simple you had Network television the
network television was funded by the
sponsors if you made a great show the
more expensive that if you made a great
show that a lot of people watched
the more ad Revenue you would generate
and that ad Revenue would pay for
you know salaries and it was just money
was flowing you had four or five
networks and that was it right then
Along Comes cable and it you know it
changed the pay scale which I don't
understand why I never understood that
because it doesn't make any sense that I
have to pay for cable and watch
commercials so that seems like people
are double dipping someplace right but
anyways
then the deals changed you know but it
still was based off you know
you had
TNT for instance if you're on a show on
TNT they have commercials and so
therefore you can decide like you know
how you're going to pay
People based off that man Rachel's hair
is how did Rachel's hair get into my hat
it's crazy anyways I don't know if you
have a wife with long hair but their
hair is everywhere always so I don't
know
um
so then now you come to the streaming
services now here's my big issue with
the the rider strike not even about the
rider strike but about how do you pay
residuals
how do you quantify it so this is my
thing I want to comment about and if
you're an actor out there and you you
have some thoughts or if you're not and
you just have some thoughts about it I'd
love to hear
how
do you quantify
what's the calculation say for a show or
movie that's on Netflix how do you
determine
what this show should be paid
is it all viewership but even viewership
is like everybody already has Netflix so
if you already have it
and you're watching a bunch of shows
just because like a new show is getting
more love because it's new and being
pumped does that mean that that show
should get a large sum how do you decide
it
it's easy to like determine like let's
say it's a show like friends or Seinfeld
or something like that and they go hey
we're gonna buy this show
and then we tell everybody Seinfeld is
coming to Netflix and then because of
that there's five million new
subscribers oh well then you could go oh
well this is because of this that'd be
one way but I don't know of the 19 I pay
or however much it is every time I watch
a show
should
I should a show get a portion of the
money that I but what if you watch a
hundred shows how do you determine how
you what's the calculation like what's
the formula
for
paying people on these streaming
services and here's like the thing that
really um that I was thinking about too
who pays the salaries so here you have
Netflix let's say Netflix and he Netflix
people have this deal with like Shonda
Rhimes for instance if you know who that
is she makes Gray's Anatomy she made a
bunch of shows on ABC right uh you know
she she uh Scandal and those kind of
shows or how to get great shows but they
were that was on ABC so there was
commercials and you have so then Netflix
goes hey we're gonna grab you from there
and we're going to pay you 300 million
dollars to make shows okay so here's my
question who then pays
the actors and production like is it the
production company
so if Netflix gives a production company
a bunch of money and says hey make some
shows
who's responsible to pay the actors and
writers
and grips and people that work on the
show is it Netflix or is it the
production company
who pays
this is the thing I would like to know
like if it's a Netflix original and
they're like okay we're making the show
and they are the production company then
yeah then they're probably the ones like
all right we're paying uh the salaries
and we're paying all the stuff but like
if you're paying some producer like Ryan
Murphy for instance if Ryan Murphy's
production company has a deal with
Netflix and they pay him
500 million dollars create 10 shows is
it the responsibility now of Ryan
Murphy's Company to pay writers and
actors or is it still Netflix
these are questions that I would like
answered so I don't know I'm just
putting it out there maybe somebody in
here knows about this kind of stuff I
don't know but I feel like that this is
going to be a bigger deal than people
are making like that it's going to take
longer to settle this than people think
because it's easy to look at the
streaming services and be like oh man
you guys are money hungry greedy but
they're like hey we're providing a
service that you like
you know what I mean like if I provide
you with service that only costs you a
hundred dollars a year right
it cost you 100 you're saying oh wow for
100 a year I get all this
you like
so and then a 200 million people go hey
we like this this is great all right
that that's the service they provided so
they've that's the money they're making
and then they're taking that money and
like you know making stuff with the
money so we can have content uh I guess
how did how you determine who gets paid
is it's important but like I think it's
gonna be it's a more nuanced there's my
favorite word
it's a more nuanced
um discussion
and it's not just like oh the evil
streaming companies because you know I
feel like
in some cases that's probably what it is
but in other cases it's like the there's
some really rich producers getting a lot
of money and not paying it out you know
they're like keeping it for themselves
they're like all right I'm creating
shows and I'm taking this money and I'm
keeping it and I'm only paying the
minimum to people to be on my show for
I'm only paying actors the minimum to
create shows apart so I think that the
production companies need to be held to
the fire as well or maybe I'm just
completely off base but I don't know but
when I look at my checks from some shows
they don't say Netflix on the check it
says certain production company you know
like when I did murder mystery that was
Happy Madison that wasn't Netflix
I didn't get paid by Netflix
even though Netflix
does send residual they send a residual
they did some kind of thing where
they're making some people get residuals
Something That We're next Netflix but
it's not a lot it's not like I'm not
living off of murder mystery money you
know even though it was one of the
biggest movies in Netflix and I had a
very small part you know so whatever
money I made on that like let me tell
you I can't make a living off of like I
remember the first year of Workaholics
actually guys first year Workaholics
that was basic cable Comedy Central
Comedy Central on page State you think
the streaming service is pay bad ah
hahaha
man if I was only doing acting the first
year of Workaholics I would have had to
get a regular job to pay my bills just
FYI okay
so I had to do stand up and do a bunch
of other stuff
on a TV show I would have had to get a
regular job that's how bad the pay was
year one of Workaholics FYI okay so
anyways
oh
yeah
so there's um my thoughts on the rider
strike uh and uh I think it's gonna go a
while to figure out the particulars and
the directors and the and the um actors
Union might jump in too to be like yo
let's get this figured out let's get
this figured out how we're gonna do this
like sag do your job you know so we'll
see how it plays out man but for now you
know I don't think there's an end in
sight that's just my opinion but again I
could be wrong
okay
daddy could be wrong
all right
um here's some music let's go over some
news and notes here's another crazy
story that you know
that I have some thoughts about y'all
um wait why is this what is this little
ad area these [__] things all right
here we go
um let's go to this okay so
you know you go you're in the self
checkout right this is this is a story
about this self-checkout so the
customers are being asked to tip even at
self-checkout
some say it's emotional blackmail
hold up
so
I gotta do your job
and tip you like hell to the gnaw that's
not how it's gonna work son
first of all
I don't even like the fact that there's
a tip line
you know when you go to a restaurant and
you picking up food
and you get you know you get there you
go and you go yeah can I get such or
even you order at the counter hey can I
get this and this and that and then they
go get it and then they bring it
it's like and then there's a tip line
and I'm looking at that like nah
sometimes I'm not into that
I don't think you going above and beyond
what you you're paid to do right here
you know it's like it's like have a jar
I don't know
I don't know how you feel about that
like it's like you go to Starbucks
you go to Starbucks and then like the
person's working and you go oh thanks
and you can leave a tip it's like you're
saying all right I know thank you for
doing what you're doing and I know
you're not making a lot so here's a
little extra for that person or like
even on the app they'll have that you
know you you pay with the app on
Starbucks and then it says do you want
to leave a tip for these people and
sometimes you're like yeah I don't mind
doing that I'm like all right here's a
tip but for some reason for me like when
I go to a restaurant that this is their
like this is a place where you're
supposed to go and sit down and you're
tipping because of the service that they
do then I'm like all right yeah I'm
gonna leave 20 20 plus to the to the
wait staff but when you're just at the
counter
you go to the thing and the person like
oh hey your food's ready they just hand
it to you I don't think that deserves a
20 tip
that's just me
okay so I'll be like all right thank you
for grabbing that bag and putting it
here for me so maybe here's three
dollars I don't know how you feel about
it but there is a time and place I feel
like in your mind like I like to tip now
but sometimes I don't like the tip
depending on the type of service that
you're getting
it's like so in this situation at a
supermarket
I'm doing the work so I gotta go get all
my groceries put it in the cart
come over to the thing and then I gotta
bag everything I'm bagging everything I
gotta scan everything
and you think I'm gonna tip you who we
tipping who's getting the tip when you
at the supermarket and you doing all the
work who's getting the tip like
that's mind-blowing right there if this
is the direction we're going in
so I don't know and I'm big on tipping
like I say man I
like when I go to a restaurant I try to
tip
if you're in California I just doubled
the tax that's the easy way to figure
out the tip because the tax is something
around 10 little over 10 percent for
when you go out and and you know in
California state tax to stack taxes
sales tax
yeah let me look it up what's the sale
tax sales tax in California so I'll just
double the tip you know
um
yeah what is California sales tax let's
see this is just oh wow you go to the
website and it's like oh can you just
tell me the number you know what I mean
I hate when you have to go to the thing
that's like all this
it's like you know I mean what is the
sales tax in California just tell me
damn it
let's see a Statewide tax rate is seven
point no it's more than that
no I don't think that's right the
Statewide rate is similar in most areas
of California local jurisdiction oh wow
um no I don't think oh no here we go
California City and County sales
U.S taxes yeah there it is right there
the tax rate is 9.5 oh okay yeah that's
what I thought I knew it was more than
that
I know it's close to 10 when you buy
something so that's not right I don't
know what that maybe I'm looking at
something else
9.75 yeah yeah so it's 9.7 so it's close
to 10 is what I'm saying so I just
double it and then like round up or down
I like when you go and on the receipt it
says
20 percent
it'll be like 18 20 22 percent
don't go over 22 like I hate when they
do that I was in where was I I was
someplace and it said 20
22 then it said like 25 I'm like what
you're not getting 25 percent
I don't know I have a weird tipping
thing I think it also depends on where
you are I think there should be a
minimum and a maximum so like if I go
get coffee from a place and I sit down
at a diner and let's say I get I just
get coffee and the bill comes and it's
only like you know it's like four
dollars whatever I am I still might
leave five dollar tip because the person
still is doing all the same type of work
you know just because I'm at Denny's and
I only spend twenty dollars
so that's not a big tip
and then you go to Morton's Steakhouse
and the people are doing the same amount
of work as the people do at Denny's but
the bill is three hundred dollars
does this person deserve now thirty
dollars and the person that Denny's only
deserves four dollars for doing the same
amount of work so sometimes you got to
figure you determine like what's going
on here like if I go to a really really
fancy restaurant and the bill is like
500 I've done it before you'd be like
well wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I don't know if you getting a hundred
dollar tip bro or 50 75 tip you know I
don't know if I'm doing that just 25 is
still really good you know so I don't
know
yeah L.A county is 13 wow that's crazy
so anyways that's uh I just thought that
was like I thought that was crazy man
I mean it's like you're tipping
um oh man we're already it's already
time's already up man
um you know let's let's give a quick rip
to MTV News so apparently MTV News
they're ending their 36 year run
first of all I don't even know that MTV
was still a thing
I can't tell you the last time I turned
on MTV
but apparently MTV is not
um
first of all they don't even play music
anymore so I don't even know what this
even matters
yeah empty it's weird how these places
man MTV doesn't make music Comedy
Central doesn't play comedy The Weather
Channel doesn't play weather uh the
History Channel doesn't show history The
Learning Channel you don't learn [__]
what's going on with these stations man
what are we doing on there
MTV
I think
I don't know uh I'll go back to it next
week and then we'll talk about
we'll talk about what we think about MTV
and in the last you know
few years of what it's been because I
remember TRL total total whatever that
what was what was TRL stand for but I
remember TRL I thought that was a really
great show I thought that was one of the
most influential shows of our time
because of it it shattered the the
genres so it just became about these are
the most popular songs and what ended up
happening is it could be country pop rap
hip-hop it was all these different
things and then young people were like
yeah we like all this and it just really
made popular music it made it made
popular music where it didn't have to be
segregated so I thought that was like
yeah I thought that was a great uh I
thought that was a great show so I might
go back to that and talk about it next
week
but anyways y'all I wanna oh wait what's
going on
anyways I want to thank you guys for
listening as always
listening to riffing with Griffin now
thanks for being here y'all are always
uh I don't know I just I appreciate the
the support that I get from a lot of you
a lot of guys hit me up and they come in
my twitch you know you guys are super
supportive so make sure you hit the uh
subscribe button and all that you know
like I say I'm on Twitch you can support
me there and you can also support me on
patreon if you just want to support I am
going to do some stuff man I promise you
I will you know you know how it is you
know so you know what time it is y'all
yeah
it's that time the rock recap
[Music]
thanks for being here
not in fear
nobody is not gonna say that oh
MBA is good
silent
Underground
I got a tip
when I go to the grocery store
I don't like it
they treat me like a [__]
MTV News is gone
it's about time
[Music]
watch the NBA
and then watch Griffin
thank you for being here if you got a
beat send it over here
all right y'all thanks again
for watching
wouldn't it be this loud
all right
see you next week
[Music]